The Council yesterday held its monthly meeting
for October, and early on the agenda was the
topic of speed limits in the Rangiora-Woodend
road area.
Following community feedback, Council staff
are proposing that speed limits be reduced
along sections of Rangiora-Woodend Road, Gressons
Road, Boys Road & Northbrook Road.
Councillors approved public consultation on
the proposed changes, which is due to start
on the 8th of October.
The Council also adopted the provisional Local
Alcohol Policy 2018.
Changes from the previous policy attempt to
make rules around opening hours consistent
between on-licensed & off-licensed premises.
It also proposes that on-license opening hours
for the day proceeding a public holiday be
treated the same as weekends.
The policy will return to the Council for
adoption once the appeal process is completed.
Finally, the Council extended the District
Road Maintenance contract for one further year.
The contract is currently awarded to Sicon.
They have performed consistently well in quarterly
performance reviews, however some Councillors
expressed their desire to see a higher level
of service.
Overall the district’s roading network is
judged as being in good condition and above
average when compared nationally.